here in this video we shall talk about
two of the most famous
and notorious lovecraft creations nail
lathotep and cthulhu
i will start first with nylathotha also
known as the crawling chaos
the black pharaoh among others this
particular monstrous entity made its
first appearance in a short story
written in 1920
the author was inspired by one of his
terrifying nightmares
supposedly he wrote this first paragraph
of this tale
immediately after he woke up from his
dream here this creature is shown to
have
taken the form of an egyptian pharaoh
hence
unlike most of the other gods or
monsters within the lovecraft universe
niolathotep can be considered to be the
most human-like
although he's not human he can manifest
himself in a human-like
image which people can't comprehend
niolathadep
acts as a kind of an intermediary
between the realms of the outer gods and
those like humans
are the great old ones hence he is also
called the messenger of the outer gods
he is a descendant of azeroth and is
classified as a god
within the same level as his grandparent
nia lathotep has to follow the commands
of azeroth but he does so
unwillingly and with resentment there is
no real affection between the two family
members
also nylathotep distinguishes himself
from azeroth by being malignant
and possessing an intelligence of a
functioning kind the
idiot god azidoth despite his terrifying
nature does not in any way receive
pleasure or even thinks about doing
anything naialathotep gives the
impression of being a sadist who enjoys
manipulating humans and inflicting pain
on them
among many of his abilities nylathop is
a shapeshifter who can morph into
or mimic any form for this reason he is
known as a faceless god
he is also able to manipulate reality or
the physical universe itself
he can bend the laws of nature to his
will at one point
he caused a great disaster throughout
the world where the majority of
earth's landmass is swallowed up by the
oceans his powers cannot be fully
measured but in
many stories he has shown himself to be
more than formidable
added to this neil latham is immortal
his antics will continue
for as long as he chooses and humans are
only his slaves and
toys and on the other hand we have
cthulhu
who is lovecraft's most famous creation
and hence the entire mythology is also
named after
him cathedral is inspired by the
writer's own hydrophobia
nylathotep's home is outside the known
limits of space but cathulis abode is
earth itself
specifically relia which is at the
bottom of the pacific ocean
he represents that part of the unknown
which is closer to us and yet
which we have not fully been able to
explore the darkness of the ocean and
this creature is representative of the
dangerous elements that are closer to us
but which we have only a vague sense of
this malevolent entity is classified as
belonging to the rank of the great old
ones
and this character first appeared in the
call of cthulhu where he is portrayed as
a horrifying creature who sleeps under
the ocean
in the city of arlier he has a great
cult of worshippers who await his
liberation
it is believed that once he rises from
the depths he will rule over the earth
and cause chaos by stripping men off
their sense of right and wrong
through him they will learn the euphoria
that comes with immorality
and take a dionysian or bacchanalian
revelry in the act of killing
a new holocaust will emerge unlike in
the case of nair lathotep
lovecraft does give us some definite
details about cthulhu's grotesque form
he is a chimera monster in the sense
that his body is composed of parts that
are not
usually seen as belonging together his
body is a combination of an octopus
with tentacles growing from the chin a
dragon fish like scales
and human parts he also has a pair of
basic and crude
wings that kinda look draconian while
many artists and writers since lovecraft
have come up with their own personal
visions of what cthulhu looks like
these elements of his form have more or
less stayed the same cthulhu's powers
are beyond our imagination and
understanding our knowledge of them is
only partial
cthulhu is certainly immense in size and
his strength is vast
he is also delaphatic and can sense what
is happening in the world
around him he can be considered to be
omniscient he can control people's minds
through
their dreams and like nail ather cthulhu
is also a descendant of the great
azidoth and hence
he is also immortal now coming to the
question of who would win in a battle
between these two titans
the answer at first seems to be nair
letharta being that nairo latitude is an
outer god
his abilities will be far superior to
that of a lower ranked god like cthulhu
nayar lathatip can metamorphose into any
creature far bigger and stronger than
cthulhu
in fact there are other entities within
the mythos who can defeat cthulhu
and cthulhu can use humans as a spawn in
the battle but that might not prove to
be enough since niolathotip can also do
the same
since both of them are immortal defeat
doesn't mean that
either of them must die the tunis
omniscience might enable him to predict
the moves of nail ather but
neither leathertop can also do the same
so how can
one defeat the other unless cthulhu is
aided by an outer god
nail lathertep's victory is assured the
only win that the former can manage is
when it comes to destroying humanity
itself
while knight leftup likes to have
mankind as his plaything
and he is having so much fun with them
that he might hesitate to destroy them
all cthulhu on the other hand
seems to have no reason to spare humans
at all he does not require our existence
or for any emotional fulfillment hence
in this area he might be able to claim
superiority
since they can't kill each other they
might as well play games with us
and that's it for today do subscribe to
be a part of the minecube family
and hit that bell button for regular
updates on monster videos
till the next one take care fam